there are many very cool things about
this job one of them is getting to wear
a dress that does this sorry personal
moment okay even better is getting to
breathe the same air as this next
presenter ladies and gentlemen Oprah
Winfrey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after 83 years of Oscars here's one
thing we know for sure if we're feeling
lousy if the news is bad and people are
hurting what do we do we go to the
movies and we escape but I'm here to
present the award to the best movie that
did not let us escape the outstanding
documentary of the year and this was an
incredible year for documentaries with
so many brilliant filmmakers working in
all regions of the globe telling their
stories illuminating the human condition
and showing us beauty insights and the
truth many do this against great odds
some are even imprisoned for their
efforts but it has never been more
important for us to see these stories to
help us try to make some sense of the
world we live in here are the nominees
for Best Documentary Feature exit
through the gift shop
Banksy and Jaime de Cruz gasolin Josh
Fox and Trish a classic inside job
Charles Ferguson and Audrey Mars
Restrepo Tim Hetherington and Sebastian
Junger wasteland
Lucy Walker and Angus eggs literally and
the Oscar goes to
inside job Charles Ferguson and Audrey
Mars
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Charles Ferguson
and other lawyers
your first nomination was for their
documentary no end in sight
forgive me I must start by pointing out
that three years after a horrific
financial crisis caused by massive fraud
not a single financial executive has
gone to jail and that's wrong thank you
but this is this is also this is about
the movies in fact that's what this is
so thank you all for this profound honor
you've made us very very happy thank you
all let the record show I'm not wearing
jeans having only made two films I still
feel that Charles and I are newcomers to
this community but from the beginning
we've been made to feel incredibly
welcomed and supported for which I'm
immensely grateful thank you so much to
the Academy and to Sony classics Michael
and Tom and much love and gratitude to
my family thank you so much thank you